now there's one question I have to ask
tell me who's the most important person
at the Keating who is it
Eddie bun yeah the most important person
at the Keating sander who is it I gotta
say it's Eddie I mean I I believe it
would be Eddie Eddie
Sandra no no the most important person
at the Keating is their guest and I
think it's all being forgotten about and
it's more about keeping you ready happy
we have to focus on the guests I'm here
to put this place right understand that
Eddie and Sandra just come with me
if Eddie won't listen to me and he won't
listen to his staff maybe you'll listen
to the people who could pay the bills
around here
Eddie up until now this hotel has always
been about you your dream your vision
now it's about the guests wait to meet
some very important people I'm just
really worried right now I've no idea
what Gordon has in the room hello I see
guess being stayin at the Keating over
the last 24 to 48 hours are not when I
see all those guests there I want to run
away right now I wanted to give you a
unique opportunity to hear some very and
I mean very valuable feedback
I've also stayed here and I am
frustrated but I'm here to get this
place back on the map give me a little
insight please what do you think of this
luxury hotel madam or you walked into
the room in itself horrible there is the
rest of the jacuzzi no water some of the
features in the room are just lower
quality like the plastic looked a little
bit cheap and old
I just feel like this place's design
kind of form over function it was kind
of weird first one's supposed to fit me
breakfast in their room my husband had
to stand up this morning to have this
breakfast line took the only chair and
sat at the dance I'm sorry our room
service at the Blue Zone we ordered a
couple the small pizzas and they
essentially looked like microwave pizzas
and then the order is wrong because we
called the cracks they eventually
brought up what we actually worked and
then in the morning they charged us for
both Wow I'm sorry anybody else there
was some really high-end stuff and then
at the same time there is just simple
amenities that were skipped are you
saying this better at the same price out
there yeah Eddie your baby your vision
and on the back of that feedback
I appreciate the feedback I have one
question for you all who would return
here let's do a show of hands who come
back to the kitchen Wow not one person
Borden's comment about it's not what I
want it's what the guests want well I'm
starting to realize that some of the
things he's saying actually are true
I really apologize and I am looking
forward to having you guys in the future
I can tell you will have a different
experience Eddie and something you know
I'm not trying to embarrass you but this
is for me
critical feedback and it's only gonna
get better the feedback from the
customer was good I'm realizing there's
more issues and I thought we had and
just being here over the past couple
days I'm seeing what they are I think we
can definitely fix them and streamline
them so the place works a lot more
efficiently and all the guests are happy
thank you I appreciate it
Eddie is starting to see how much things
have to change for this place to succeed
but for the hotel to have a fighting
chance of turning a profit I've got to
find a way to reignite chef Brian's love
of cooking they show the gang what we
can do
yeah I don't have much passion here
anymore I'm hoping that Gordon being
here will nurse him back and breakfast
was the roasted beet and burrata salad
that has been seasoned with a little
touch of salt pepper and then finished
in a little hazelnut vinaigrette
scallops I like serving scallops with a
nice sear
so touch a salt pepper a little bit of
vinaigrette I've just made it sort of
citrusy it's cute so I love it we get
excited like that you know energy coming
back and I absolutely love it
what's that little taste
are you okay Brian
you're killing me on the onion puree
when I'm on the line with Gordon the
energy level just pops up and now I'm
you know standing a little taller and
it's exciting nice happy yeah so nice to
see you smiling you know that Gordon
kind of unlocked the chains that I had
allowed to be put on I'm with you every
step of the way but you need a voice in
here and your voice is on that plate let
it scream